hello there I'm Gavin I'm Dan we're the
slow mo guys today's video was inspired
by a memory I had of being in primary
school and I was a youngin
there is no sir not again well you know
not that much
there was a snob ed in my class we
thought it'd be a great idea if you sort
of take the lid off a felt pen and then
go through and it causes a lot of the
ink to classic fly out and get my nice
white button-up all messy so you the
victim I had all along you were the knob
doing that's people I think nowadays I'd
be the knob ed but back then I was just
like oh I do wash it again yeah still
work these days you want testing else if
physics has changed it's 1996 stay there
yeah you got caked you know I'm gonna be
the clean one oh nice so obvious as well
it still works
do you think your mom will do the
washing again before you know I live a
lot further away from her that I did oh
yeah the midnight is I've done a machine
gun version you're right got lots of
different pens all super glued to one
disc I'm gonna attach it to a drill and
spin them and hopefully get like ten
coming at the same time what you've done
there is you've slow mo guys dit yeah I
think it'll look nice
yeah for this video we're using the loud
boy the 25:11 thanks to Destin from
smarter every day how we're gonna mount
this so you're gonna help me show the
bit through here we're gonna try and
attach it with the drill so if you just
hold it nicely all right then let's see
if your contraption works here we go
LD yep
oh gee peak overhunting goober that's
lovely
oh my goodness Wow it works
well it's really well hey yep it's like
erupting from I thought it would just
come off the top of the felt like the
but it's it's really blowing out the
sides of it there's such force I think
there's like little icky bits for it to
allow that maybe for emergencies such as
this maybe the designer of all these
pens was that nob edited out also the
nut is spinning freely in the disk yeah
I also didn't tie it up enough so we
could actually spin it faster we've also
got fatter pens
I see if these have little flow holes
like they were no oh yes oh yeah they do
like a little vent hole I like it wink
then all right guy you're not that was
so much more oh the fat pendant waver
Oh get some paper towel and go for it
I'm gonna frame up I'm sort of the
splash alaria the special is special so
hopefully I'll land somewhere in there
three two one
Oh
that should look lovely yeah sounds like
a little line and as it gets faster it's
like coming out the side of it
[Music]
Oh Solomon so as it picks up speed look
ever leading into reality
[Music]
there's some holes of ink there yeah
absolute pearls now we switch to the
Fenton flex for K just for some really
nice high res but not as fast footage
should look nice brand new canvas well
you can hold this one down a little bit
longer because we got more time okay so
maybe like three second pump okay three
two one
start looks like a spaceship going
through you know in like something
spinning down like I said to me from
Star Wars
I like the star war you know damn it the
stairway feel like it may be about to
escalate I know that when I'm looking at
that snowbirds gonna all right I also
know that I used to be one of the kids
that used to do that to people
I used to flick people with rubber bands
as well they were they were there yeah
yeah yeah
so you're gonna take it in the face
basically I think I want to make up for
all the times I've done it to people and
send people home looking like that so
I'm sure all to myself in one go
yeah I'm sure everyone who got penned
will appreciate you sort of repaying the
universe much think so all right well I
probably only have one go this because
you're gonna absolutely ravaged with ink
yeah I'm quite excited I hope I hope we
don't deny like that meat is a slight
issue I'll try and point away from it I
hope these pens don't come off that's
gonna go well er but we haven't had any
fire off yet no okay you ready yeah go
for it
three two one Oh Oh you sure
why don't we ever think beyond like this
everywhere oh I don't know I was
thinking I was like doing that
absolutely perforated
man did you open your mouth eventually
oh yes like what contraption how do I
look you look quite good yeah you look
pretty good let me get a little shot of
that oh it's finally time like itch it's
not the worst look I've ever seen that
you've had oh really do you want to take
the off the the goggles hmm slightly
worse now oh really
oh you can see my face it's quite
pleasing looking footage isn't it
yeah yeah quite satisfying to use this
as well I think colours spinning just
always looks good do you think power
tools at school would have been round
upon or what for like year 3r yeah yeah
well I was just making clay knobs at
that play I'm quite proud of our art
though yeah maybe we should put this in
the museum or give it away one day yeah
nice I think I need a shower
cuz I'm caked and you need a pressure
hose or something I mean like it's like
a Star Trek sonic shower it's like in
your bed let's blast it through your
beard don't be surprised if it stays on
for weeks
well if you see Dan looking like this in
the next video you know what happened
yep alright we'll see you in the next
video feel free to subscribe
and now we've got a second channel too
if you'd like maybe we should make a
bigger one well I could propeller your
plane propeller will paint a runway